Hello,
and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy. My
name is David Flanagan, I am your host
for today on this episode of Rawkode Live.
Rawkode Live is a show where we take
a look at all the best open source
tools and technologies solving real world problems in
the cloud native and Kubernetes ecosystem.
And today,
we are taking a look at something I'm
very excited to play with, Namespace.
Joining us today to introduce us to Namespace
is
Hugo. Hey, Hugo. How's it going? Hey, David.
It's going great. Apart from the fact that
they've been a little bit under the weather,
we had a you know, kids were sick,
then I'm sick. It just goes around.
But it's actually a great time right now
and just getting into
past fall and into winter.
And every day is
actually super exciting about seeing started to talk
a little bit about what we're doing and
and getting people engaging with the product. So
super excited about that. Awesome. Well, I'm very
excited to sit down and spend some time
with you today, learning more, kicking tires and
having some fun. And I will also just
segue and confirm what you said. Yeah. When
my kids get sick, I am sick the
following two days afterwards. And then it seems
to be on this wild loop. Someone in
their school gets sick. They get sick. I
get sick. My wife gets sick and I'm
look, look, look. I feel that pain.
Alright, awesome. So
before we
talk about namespace,
do you want to share a little bit
more information about you who you are, what
you're up to? Just give us the who
who is Hugo.
Yeah.
You know, I and it's actually thank you
for the opportunity. It's really exciting to to
spend some time with you and and your
audience.
I've been living in a cave for many
years and and I'm
living that cave now and it's actually very
exciting. But but the story starts early. I
I'm a software engineer
at heart and I've been I've been thinking
about software and and working on software for
as long as I remember.
When I was 15, I sold my first
piece of software that I wrote for BOS.
And Wow.
Trying really hard to make that my main
operating system after a stint. Like, my first
system was Windows and spent some time on
Linux. Red Hat 5.2 was my first distribution.
Then then tried to do kinda run macOS
eight
fully emulated.
It's it's because I really wanted to run
a Mac and then, moved over to POS,
which was the kind of closest thing. And
I that was kind of part of my
journey just exploring, figuring out things by by
myself.
Then later on college, spent a lot of
time on open source, very focused on
networking
and networking infrastructure
and authentication
and these types of challenges, which I still
have
a a passion for, although I don't spend
as much time there nowadays.
And
college was was done then kind of did
a regular job as as many of us
do and but then the I started getting
a hitch of of of wanting to start
something by myself and
and move over to Finland. I'm originally from
Portugal.
I had moved to Germany to
to move to The to kind of for
my first job, and then I moved to
Finland to start the company. This was 02/2010
doing,
well, kind of edge computing. Before edge computing
was really a thing, we were streaming smartphone
like experiences
to feature phones. And it was
a great time,
not not because of the point in time.
02/2010 was really after a recession, so probably
one of the worst times to start the
company,
but, like, putting
together a team and and just working on
the technology was was really exciting.
But we couldn't make the business work.
So a couple years later, we
kind of the company got transformed,
and it was bought by Facebook. But just
before that, I Google had been asking me,
hey. Do you want a guy do you
wanna come and and spend some time with
us? I I had a couple friends there,
and I said, why not? So I I
moved to Switzerland where I've been since now
it's been almost ten years.
And at Google, I I worked on I
I've always worked on software infrastructure.
Actually, I tried to stint at consumer, but
almost next day, I was back at, hey,
guys. Have you seen this infrastructure
problem that we have?
And and, yeah, at Google, I had kind
of two major journeys. One was building
or helping to build Google's internal development platform
or application platform called Bock,
which, unfortunately, we never really spent a lot
of time talking about it externally.
We we'll we'll get back with, I guess,
a little bit later. And, and then as
part of kind of helping the company move
over to Bock,
I I got to work with search, and
I got really passionate about search. So I
joined the the search team and, in particular,
the assistant team that works on all the
kinda smart devices,
like speakers and displays and other things. So
I helped build kind of the infrastructure and
the platform for for that organization as well.
And after those two, I I really was
craving kind of going back to
to my kind of startup roots, if you
can call them that. And and I I
I left the company last year,
and I it's was a tremendous experience. But
I I wanted to start something from scratch,
and I was going back to actually some
of those kinda early infrastructure
ideas,
and I was playing around with some soft
software defined storage. That's another passion of mine.
And as I was building that, I I
got to experience a lot of the challenges
that then I got to learn that a
lot of folks, do do experience as well.
Like, okay. I need I have the GoControl
plane. What's what's the best way for me
to do kind of incremental builds? Or I
have multiple services, and they need to authenticate,
with each other what's kind of the right
way to do that,
and what's kind of the right deployment strategy.
So this whole life
cycle of going from code into having something
meaningful
running in production,
I was finding myself
answering those questions
like, kinda on a on a case by
case basis.
And I thought there must be a better
way. And and, actually, I got to learn
about a lot of good technology that is
out there,
but we we feel like
that there's more that we can do to
really help, ourselves, actually, first and foremost,
but then a broader set of of developer
teams,
to to just go well, go faster,
and and have the confidence that you're building
kind of on a world class
platform or infrastructure, and you can focus on
your application. So that gets us to Namespace
we're at today.
Awesome. Thank you for sharing. I'll go back
to the first thing you said, which is
you're a software developer at heart. That's why
I describe myself these days because I never
get to actually write any software anymore.
So
it says, you know, you've got a lot
of experience having worked on search, the assistant
and for such a problems at Google, signing
a company like that is a lot of
things over many years. And I'm hoping that
what we're gonna look at today with
Namespace
as you condensing
these many years of
pains, failures, experience and challenging things into something
that's really gonna resonate with our audience today.
So when real world problems that a lot
of people face during this,
I don't know, epidemic of Kubernetes adoption. I
don't know. Like, is it a pandemic?
Like we see a lot of traction towards
Kubernetes. This right. It's now almost the ubiquitous
way to build and run applications at scale.
Even for people that aren't at scale, which
I see even more of now than people
at proper scale. However, Kubernetes as that API
that keeps us cloud agnostic to a certain
degree, but it comes with many, many, many
challenges.
And one of them, it's what we're gonna
talk about today. It's like, how do we
get that joyful developer experience and deployment pipeline
back.
So I wanna I wanna learn. I wanna
take all this experience out of your head
and I wanna see a really cool product
today. That that's our mission.
Sounds great.
And and for it's worth, we we we're
actually very inspired by by not just Kubernetes,
the technology, but by the the kind of
the ecosystem around it.
A tremendous amount of respect for for what,
like, so many people have worked and and
put together.
But, yeah, like, approaching it from from
I just want to get my application out
there, and I want to use this infrastructure
for my benefit. Benefit.
Like, I want to benefit from this ecosystem,
from this Kubernetes ecosystem,
but not having to make that my full
time job of, actually, how do I make
this work for me? That's that's really part
of what we're what we're about. Like and
and we'll learn that, obviously, you need to
make certain trade offs on the way, and
we'll talk a little bit, hopefully about those.
But,
but we care deeply about this application centric,
philosophy that builds on great infrastructure.
Awesome. It looks like we have one of
your colleagues in the chat. Happy to help
with questions as well. Carol. Hello, Carol. Nice
to meet you.
Alright. Let's
give everybody a little bit of an overview
on our namespace today. What are we going
to be taking a look at? What problems
does it wanna solve? And how is it
different from other tools in the space? I'll
let you answer them in whatever order you
want. Go nuts.
Yeah. Let me preface by we're we're early.
Like, we we know we're we're at the
beginning of a journey. Like, we have
we have an idea of where we're going
based on both our our experience as software
engineers ourselves and and kind of building applications,
but but also what we've been learning from
from folks in different companies. But
you you'll hear a snapshot that makes sense
for us today, but I it is likely
that as we go over time, it that
that story will also shift. But where we
are today is
and and what folks can already try, is
that we have a alpha version of an
application platform.
We call it an end to end application
platform that builds on Kubernetes. It's end to
end because it focuses on your whole development
experience, not just
kind of building, not just testing, not just
deployment,
but but how do these three things kinda
work together so that you can just write
code
and kinda compose infrastructure and ship it to
production
without having to kind of on the way
go and figure out,
kind of individual parts of the story. So
Namespace
is it kind of facilitates you. It kinda
helps you build your application.
It helps you build an application that is
composed of multiple services, but it's really up
to you of how many services those those
are. It helps you whether you're in a
single repository or multiple repositories. So it takes
all of these kind of real world problems
that folks are are facing
and and tries to package it in a
developer
experience centric
platform that
brings you build. So you can you you
can you work with code, and we build
images for you.
It brings you testing so you can both
do you know, more constrained testing, but it
also allows you to do, like, whole what
we call old system testing. So actually replicating
production like stack for for testing purposes. And
then you can also ship that code that
you've been writing and that we built
to production.
And it does that exclusively over Kubernetes today.
And the experience we're aiming for we're aiming
for an experience that is much more like
Docker Compose, which like, tremendous amount of respect
for Docker has been kinda instrumental in the
industry,
but but it's not confined to development. It
actually goes all the way to fairly complex
scenarios as well. And,
yeah, that's that's a little bit of of
of what we're about.
Awesome.
Alright. Naveen asking in the comments. Are we
going to just talk? Are we going to
show a demo? Of course, we're gonna do
a demo, Naveen. Come on.
This is the hands on show. We don't
we don't just talk.
So
let's just cover a couple more questions and
then we will jump over to the demo
and we'll take a look at it in
action.
Why
why do we need a new tool for
this?
Like, I don't that's not a disparaging comment.
It's kind of a passing question. I
remember speaking to Brian Grant
at Google,
about the saturation of this marketplace,
And not that saturated with
I think he said there were over 400
or 500 tools in the spreadsheet that he's
got for different tools all deployed to Kubernetes.
And I think that is kind of an
affirming position because clearly deploying to Kubernetes is
a bit of a challenge. We don't have
500 different tools for the sake of having
500 different tools. I think we have 500
different tools because
there's different opinions on what that pipeline, what
that process should look like. Yeah. I'm curious
what
Why Namespace? Why now? And why is it
different?
Yeah. That's a great question.
And I I won't pretend to
to to to say I won't I won't
say that there's like an exact answer to
it. I think part of the answer is,
we do have
first of all, well, we look at the
the the technology of these already out there.
It's great. And and I think folks have
been doing a great job at delivering individual
tools for individual problems that really nail those
problems really well. And that's great. Like, if
you want to do authentication,
you have a few different options out there.
They're really solid, and that's great.
But what what do we see kind of
over and over is that
many teams,
and and if you're an engineer in in
a in whether it's a startup or midsize
company or or whatever size company,
you're still it's still up to you to
kind of go and figure out how you
put those things together. And there are a
few approaches to it out there in the
industry. We believe that
something that kinda brings development
closer to production is is kind of instrumental
on not just from a technology perspective, but
also from how we work together. Like, I
think one of the interesting and and things
that I'm actually most proud of from from
my journey back at Google was kind of
to help kind of close a little bit
the gap between the development teams and the
SRE teams. Like, kind of each one lived
in their own world.
They have this shared kind of set of
concerns, but because of the technology space was
very separate, it also meant that they were
often talking different languages,
like human languages, like programming languages,
and and just just really con being concerned
about different things. And I think technology can
be an enabler
to kinda bring groups of people together.
And,
at the fur but but the most important
thing is that we care about the mission
more so than the technology. Like, the technology
that we're building is it we feel like
it fills a gap,
that even when we look at some of
the other,
software out there, we feel like there's a
unique gap, and, hopefully, we'll we'll get to
see some of that during the hands on
today. But but first and foremost, we care
about the mission, which is helping developer teams,
helping
the DevOps teams, helping
SREs just kind of do better and and
being able to ship applications robustly.
And if on the way we figure out
there's a better kind of piece of open
source that does can do a better job
than what we do, then we'll just go
and use that. And that's already the case
today. We build on the shoulders of giants.
Kubernetes
is built in. BuildKit is built in. Queue
is built in. Like, we we already do
that, and it is very much part of
of how we approach software.
Awesome.
Look, two of those technologies you mentioned in
the last three seconds are are two of
the most exciting technologies to me that we
have in this space right now. I think
BuildKit is completely underutilized as a tool Mhmm.
Especially for CICD pipelines and as a local
development tool. And q, which I think I've
been a very loud advocate for for a
number of years now is just a language
and I use for a pretty much everything
these days. In fact, I even built a
database with that as the query language. So
so I'm really excited to sit down and
I think this would be a great time
for me to share my screen. We'll take
a look at the homepage and we'll get
started with the hands on component.
Sound good?
That's good. Awesome.
Alright, where's my screen share? There we go.
Okay, so here we have the Namespace website,
you can find us at Namespace.
So,
it says is that all in one development
platform
unified experience from development to production.
So, that's a pretty that's a pretty good
teaser right off the bat like I'm excited
about that. We've got a little code window
there that says we can set up a
cluster, develop test and deploy. So this is
our full life cycle experience situation.
Pretty strong opening, gotta say.
Well, we you know,
because I mean, we're very transparent and I
hopefully, that's something that folks will kind of
learn about us.
Like, part of part of the challenge that
we have is also
because the the industry is so focused on
individual tools, so so something that does authentication
really well or something that does deployment really
well or something that does building really well,
We we're still figuring out what's the best
way to talk about how we think about
the problem and and how we feel like
we can help teams.
And this all in one has been
kinda a a monitor that we've leaned on
for that, but I I think that there's
still there's still more work for us to
do there to kinda better explain what we're
about.
Awesome.
Alright. And just to confirm as always, I
think we said at the start, everything is
open source. Right? Everything we're looking at today
is is available. It's on GitHub. People can
can contribute and open issues and all of
that good stuff that we expect from open
source. Right? That's that's right. So it's
the everything that we're looking at is Apache
two licensed.
We actually had a couple of contributions already
that it's really
kind of fills my heart that
to see people engaging and, yeah, we're happy
to have people come over, test it out
and and contribute as well. So that's that's
definitely part of the journey.
Alright. Awesome.
Well, I'm gonna click on start from scratch.
And I'm curious if this is gonna tell
me how to nope. Doesn't tell me how
to install it. So let's find the install
instructions first. We'll we'll take notes as we
go as well, David.
There's no install instructions.
The well, if you press quick start, it
will give you
install instructions.
Alright. Let's go definitely to
bash, but I I will go for it.
Yeah.
I mean, the docs say starting from scratch.
I mean, it's almost scratch, but as long
as you've got the NS command. Right? Let's
see.
Yeah. And as many other tools
in this space, we have our our CLI.
We
we're
we're thinking about, like, some of those trade
offs. Like, one of the things that we
actually care a lot about is not having
to manage
dependencies.
We we care deeply about knowing that we're
using the right dependencies,
but you just saw some of that. Like,
you installed
NS from Brew, but it will actually the
first time that you run,
we went and fetched the latest version that
we just released an hour an
hour ago. I did notice. I was curious
why NS dash dash help
was fetching something from some sort of repository
somewhere. Right. Okay.
So just updating itself. Okay. Yep.
Alright. So and I'll just start from scratch.
We need something called a namespace workspace,
which is a directory or some sort of
NS workspace dot q file.
So I'm just gonna initialize this. When we
talk about modules,
should I think of them in the same
light as I would with with Go modules?
So typically,
github.com
slash some sort of repository.
Yeah. That's that's right. And we
we
you'll see some of some inspiration that we've
had
comes comes from Go.
That that's perhaps, like it's it's it's probably
worth kinda spending just a minute on this.
Like, Namespace
includes a module system very much like Go.
And and the reason we do that is
we're kind of tired
of having to manage dependencies
manually. And,
and you'll get you we'll see that a
little bit more during the during the hands
on,
but you'll you with Namespace, you can refer
to servers
or components, we call them resources, in any
repository in the same way that you do
with Go. Like, you just import
the the
that repository,
and we'll fetch it as as needed.
And we'll always do that in a way
that doesn't really interfere with anything else in
your machine.
We're we also like it to be very
tidy and and not kinda random software, kinda
doing random things.
But we we try to tackle as much
of this kind of figuring out what are
the dependencies, unloading those dependencies, making sure that
you're up to date
for you.
Okay.
I don't wanna jump the gun on it
too early because it sounds like a conversation
we may have further on into the session.
But when you talk about having a referencing
another repository and other packages, is this, like,
platform teams that provide building blocks for people
to deploy MongoDB or Postgres or Redis and
all these other infrastructure components?
Yeah. Like, we think of it as a
building block, and it can be applied in
multiple ways. Like, one way is what you
just described. You're you're inside of an organization,
and you have a team that is focusing
more on infrastructure, and they put together a
series of resources and resource providers as kind
of Namespace calls them. And you can import
them,
from if they're if they live in different
repository.
They can also live in the same repository.
Like, we support
kind of arbitrarily sized
mono repos.
But I think from a open source community
and ecosystem, what is really interesting is
we won't have the chance of kind of
going through that today. But imagine that you
have an application
that is,
well, what's a monitoring stack. And what do
you do today? You go to,
probably the Prometheus,
community managed Helm
page, and then it tells you, hey. Run
these commands, and now you have Prometheus.
And we we turn that into a dependency
set. You go to your application, and you
say, hey. I depend on Prometheus,
and this is kind of a one line,
import. And then when you deploy
your application, it will also automatically kind of
deploy the right Prometheus to go,
with it.
We'll see a little bit of that later
on, in the hands on, or a part
of the getting started, But the that's how
we think about,
like, kinda package management. It's it's both something
that could you can use, like, build your
own, but also
other people in the in the ecosystem can
and the community can build their own, and
then you it's very easy for you to
use them. Like, you can just make depend
on them and and you're ready to go.
Alright. Awesome.
Well, running
our edit command, got us a namespace workspace
dot q, which defines our module, some environment,
and then dependency.
I'm assuming if I were to curl this,
it would probably still too take a hub
repository somewhere, and this is likely a GET
share. I mean, I mean Yeah. That's right.
Okay. Cool.
And foundation is just
it it was for a long time, like,
maybe maybe a little bit of insider
baseball as as our our North American friends
would would say.
It was for a long time our our
internal code name,
and I think we have we have a
soft spot for for that name. So even
though the product like, we you'll often,
hear us say, namespace, and that's kind of
the platform,
a lot of the dependencies come from foundation
because that's that's
where where the core orchestration is, where the
core platform and a lot of the dependencies
live in.
Okay. Is that after the book, or have
I missed something there?
You know, you can
I'll I'll I'll I won't try to rewrite
story
rewrite history.
But I I I think
it's a name that
there's a history to it also for for
us.
The the team
and that kind of the Namespace Labs team
is
we've been working together for a while, and
and Namespace has sorry. Foundation has been a
name that showed up in our past as
well, so it's so there's a kind of
special meaning to it. Right. Okay. No worries.
Got it.
Yeah. So this takes us to some repository.
I'm sure we'll come back to this at
some point later.
Let's jump back to the kinesarctic gate.
Oh, no. No. There was a link in
the docs. I'm sorry. See it? It's there.
Would have taken you back, so that's
Alright. So now we need to do some
sort of prepare step.
So we run this, Namespace
is going to do
it's downloading k three s. You wanna fill
us in on what's happening to site.
Yeah. So
and and this is one of those things
that we would love to get feedback on,
also the the names of some of these
commands. We've actually gone back and forth on
prepare.
So what prepare is doing is it's setting
up the an environment. And
often when you don't see an environment
reference with with Namespace, the default is dev.
But
even though there's a list of, like, dev
prod and and staging in the in the
file above, actually, Namespace doesn't care. They're apart
from dev being the default, there's there's no
other special meaning to them. You can have
as many different environments as you want.
You can have, like, 10 different development environments,
cloud versions, local versions, etcetera. Doesn't really matter.
And what prepare then does, it makes sure
that you have a Kubernetes cluster set up
to be usable by namespace in that environment
as well as long with other dependencies that
we that we use. So for example, we
also set up an image registry so that
you don't have to go and figure out
how how what which registry should I be
using. So when you say prepare local,
we do run k three s inside of
Docker. We use k three d for that
purpose, which has been
fantastic to actually have that and be able
to use it. We're also big friends of
k three s. I don't want to kind
of stir any any
any any
and I I know that not everyone like,
I think I know that a lot of
folks like KIND, and we also
really
like KIND, but we started early with K3S,
and and and it's been we really appreciate
how flexible it's been for us through kind
of development and production.
And and it does a couple other things.
It also makes sure that you have an
ingress controller inside of that cluster,
which K3s by default does, obviously, with traffic,
but we we install NGINX.
And
and and then we also we have a
component
that helps orchestrate some of the things that
Namespace does that gets installed into the into
the cluster.
And that's another of one another one of
those pieces that we've kind of gone a
little bit back and forth on the design.
Like, previously, we didn't. Now we do.
And and we may still kind of change
that. But there's our orchestrator also gets deployed
into into that cluster. And after it's done,
we update a local file
dev host, we call it, which kind of
says, well, for this environment, use this cluster
that we've just set up.
Alright. Thank you. We have a question in
the chat from Diego, who's asking which image
registry is used, and are emojis encrypted and
private? Are they readable by Namespace Labs?
Yeah. It's a great question.
We're so when we when you do prepare
local, we set up an image registry inside
Docker running on your machine. So we have
no access to it.
We it's something that we we care a
lot about so that's something as well that
we're kind of been working on and we
keep working on. So we really wanted it
to be as local as possible.
We even have ideas of
having an image registry that much more closely
map maps what the containerd image
store
is like so that you don't even have,
like, an intermediate
step with images are are are stored, and
we can kind of seed containerd directly, but
we haven't done that yet. So but but
in essence, like, local things are all complete
in your machine.
We don't have access to them. You're just
using the the software.
There's other arguments to to prepare. So you
can prepare EKS,
for example.
And when you prepare EKS, we set up
an environment to use
Amazon's
image registry, so ECR.
And then if you use if you use
prepare existing, then you tell us which registry
you want to use, and that's really up
to you to decide how how that's set
up. And we
this this set of options will increase over
time.
One interesting thing is that not in the
current implementation, but kind of part of our
design ethos, if you will, is is extensibility.
We want
we we care a lot about, like, this
core experience, but we know that there's a
lot of kind of good cloud providers out
there. Not everyone is in EKS. Like, we
don't want to even
have to have, like, a strong opinion on
which cloud provider you should be using.
So over time,
we'll actually change this interface so that anyone
can build a module that does the same
type of setup,
and and it will work in a similar
way. You'll just tell us well, set up
a environment
with a module that lives in this repository,
and we'll make sure that we build it.
We we,
kind of run it for you so that
as a user, it's also something that just
works out of the But at the moment,
we have these three options that are built
into into NS.
Okay.
A question on the top of my head
is the orchestrator component.
Is this something I would run-in my production
environment if I were using Namespace?
So today, if you go and deploy to
production, you do see it there. In our
final design, no. We we
our our goal is that production becomes as
hair tie air airtight as possible.
And
the big the the the reason why we
haven't done that yet is because we care
very deeply about,
having the minimum
kind of access
necessary in order to deploy to production, and
we haven't done that in a way that
the orchestrator
will live somewhere else and deploy to your
production cluster.
We we have done that in other parts
of Namespace. So for example,
we won't go through that today, but if
you use
an s three bucket
out of AWS and you kind of instantiate
that with Namespace,
we out of the box set up an
IAM policy that is kind of the minimum
policy for you to be able to use
that that bucket
in your application. And those are the types
of things that we would want to do
as well when we're setting up production,
but we haven't gotten to it yet.
Okay.
Two questions.
Does the lack of an orchestrator in the
future in production mean that Namespace
won't adopt or support get ops patterns, or
is that something you just see being done
in a different
way?
Yeah. So the orchestrator does need to live
somewhere else.
It just
it wouldn't live inside of your cluster. So
it will live somewhere else where your GitOps
stack, if you will, would be running. So
anything that is then consuming these events, we
we we're strong believers in GitOps.
We it's something that
it was our bread and butter for many
years
and and got this idea that configuration lives
in the repository
and kinda major changes go through a review
process, and then they're deployed
from from
from the actual repository.
We care a lot about provenance. Like, do
we understand where those changes come from?
And also being able to ensure that we
have automated testing that goes into into those
changes as they're getting rolled out. So we
got big thumbs up for GitOps, and it's
it's you'll see it kind of first kinda
at at the force center in in in
Namespace.
But but, yeah, we don't see that as
kind of preventing
GitOps. We would just have the orchestra just
living somewhere else.
Okay.
Last question, and I'll let you plead the
fifth if you don't wanna answer it. But
as an ex Googler,
I see EKS, and I don't see
GCR or GKE.
Was that an intentional decision? Is that something
you plan to support longer term? Like, I'm
just curious.
Yeah. Well, we we care about
I I think the most important thing for
us is to go where users are, like,
help
people where they are. And it's no question
that a lot of folks are in AWS,
So that's that's where we started.
We have friends at Google. I I really
like Google's products.
GCP, I think, in the Kubernetes space is
probably one of the best kind of managed
Kubernetes solutions.
And
it may still show up in this mode
that is kind of built into NS,
but what I would really like to do
is just get
our extension system working
for also these
these part of the of the system, which
at the moment, it doesn't. It only works
for other parts so that whether it's ourselves
or someone else in the community can go
and build that integration.
Alright. Cool. So business decision, not a technical
decision. I like Yeah.
Okay. So I think we're prepared.
Let's see what's next. You've already covered the
dev host file.
Now we want to develop our first namespace
application.
So we need to create a server dot
queue and I'm just gonna copy and paste
all of this.
Yeah. I will do my best to
speculate about what this is gonna do, but
feel free to correct me if you wish.
Sure.
Yes. I trust myself. Yes. Good. Thank you.
Just so
well, I'll leave it up to you. There
was something in the instructions. It asked you
to put this file under a server directory.
You can see what happens if you don't,
if you want to discover a little bit.
But because later on, we're going to add
a second server so we can already be
set up for for later.
Okay. So you're right. The instructions that say
create a package directory first called server.
I'm
assuming
this is for the queue module system. So
I will just do this. But if I'm
wrong, then maybe we should dive into that
a little bit.
It's it's so queue does play a role
like we
queue also follows, as as you probably know,
well, like, the a similar model as Go
that a directory
establishes a package and the package being, like,
a a unit of of
well, in this case, configuration.
We have the same concepts. We were it's
lucky. I guess we're lucky that we all
kind of follow the same semantics.
And and similarly, so server will be a
package, so it's something that you can refer
to. And that when we're done with these
first steps, it will have both the server
definition, which is what we're seeing in front
of us, but also the code of the
server.
And and that's maybe something that is a
little bit different from some of other tools
out there.
I know that Acorn also collocates
application definition
and and code,
but but we we do and and for
for a few reasons that I'm happy to
kinda go then more into.
Well, yeah. I mean, I'm 100% in agreement
with you and Acorn. Like, I have been
working with customers and clients for for years.
I always say you're deploying code to your
developer code should all live right next to
the code that is orchestrating and working with.
And it's amazing how many times you go
to companies or speak to people at conferences
and they're like, oh yeah, we have a
repository that keeps all of that. And you're
like, why is it your code? Yeah. You're
creating a boundary that I think it's just
it just impedes your ability to ship faster.
So
That's that's right. And and it's part of
those
it's it's a human pro it's a human
challenge. Right? Like, it's
probably someone didn't feel comfortable having those configurations
there, but it's we
care deeply about kinda helping teams kinda work
better together. So it's kinda part of our
design that these that these
live next to each other.
Alright. Well, I I will help you spread
that message as well as I can. Appreciate
it. With regards to the server definition,
I understand the name. Everything should have a
name even if sometimes we struggle to name
the name. I understand the service. This looks
to me like a Kubernetes service of a
core account and ingress that got it.
I don't know what integration goal is providing
here. So maybe you can tell us in
on on this.
Yeah.
I think the interesting it's it's useful to
kinda
and since this is kinda more I I
know that your audience also
of dives deep in into a lot of
these projects. I think it's useful to
think of our system
as
has a kind of simple to use
control surface. Like, you write configuration files like
these that are very simple, and and that's
part of the goal. But behind the scenes,
it's a programmable system.
So, actually, what happens when you say integration
go,
you kick off,
kind of a decorator,
something that is going to add more definitions
to your server.
And one of those definitions is
a binary
build rule. So we'll we'll,
if you use the short form as as
you're using here, as as the example suggests
you to do, we assume that the Go
code base lives alongside the server definition,
and then we're going to instantiate
a a build rule for for building that
Go server for the code that was living
next to it.
The code will come now, as part of
the example,
but that's what the integration Go,
in this case, does. It adds a few
other things. So these decorators can actually, for
example, add services.
So we have integration web,
which
kind of the production build
builds
static
files for for serving,
And you, as a user, don't need to
say, well, here's here's where these files are
being served. We actually, it is the integration
itself that is able to
emit that that definition for you.
Okay.
Let's work through this and see if we
can get something running then. So I'm gonna
copy
main dot go.
And I wasn't reading the instructions properly, but
I'm gonna assume it goes in the top
level.
That may have been a naive assumption.
It goes in into the same directory as
server, and then and maybe that's something we
should clarify in our in our instructions.
Okay.
Next,
are going to do
and our workspace route.
Okay.
That's here.
Which gives me a GoMod and a GoSum
here. So main.Go goes in server, but the
GoMod and GoSum go here. Is that correct?
Yeah. In this example, we did it like
this. You can have multiple
GoMods
if you prefer.
We we sometimes we see different teams do
different things where where we work with both
with both systems.
Okay. Or with both models.
Yeah. Okay. Sure.
I use Go Workspaces quite a lot these
days. Is that does Namespace just work that
with that as a box that it doesn't
really care that much? Like, especially in a
mono repository environment with that. Would that be
fine?
I'll be honest with you. I don't know
whether we would actually work out of the
box with Go Workspaces. We haven't tried it.
But we so the the
way that our Go integration works, it it
it looks up in the tree looking for
the closest Go mod, very much like Go
does, and then it uses that as a
root for building.
Because whenever you want to have a referencing
to other files, other packages from a versioning
perspective,
that kind of your Go mod defines that.
So we kind of do some of the
same things that Go Workspaces tries to do
out of the box,
but I I don't know if what what
would happen if you actually put a Go
Workspaces file in there. Okay. Well, that's not
something for us to do in a livestream,
but I'll I'll I'll play with that later
on. I'll let you know. Okay.
So now that we've done this, we're going
to run NS dev server.
Now before I run this,
we
have
a workspace definition,
which doesn't tell me much.
We have a main dot goal, which is
just an issue to peer.
We have some server dot queue that tells
it to build a goal. So
when I run NS
dev, it's gonna compel the go application,
build a container image,
deploy it to
a KCS cluster and expose it with a
service on the ingress endpoint.
Yep.
That's kinda neat. Okay.
And that's There's one more thing,
which is it also
like other tools that
are this is more common in the JavaScript
or TypeScript ecosystems.
But the difference between dev and other commands
that we have is that dev listens. So
dev is stateful. It as you're doing changes,
it will redeploy those changes as well.
Okay.
I'm curious about the server. I'm assuming that's
the directory, that's the package that we're deploying.
If I do NSDev, does it do
everything or nothing?
You can write with everything. Okay.
But but right now, we'll stick to to
server.
Well, that runs. We do have another question
from Diego in the chat.
Do we still need to write Kubernetes manifest
for persistent volumes for databases like Redis or
is it automated?
If not, how do we manage scaling?
You you actually, I you you hit one
of those bugs,
but I
think it had to do
with,
yeah, the the
the module name that you use for for
the workspace.
You didn't use what we have with with
queue before. That's that's my fault.
So
a
Namespace bug. Is that right?
Yeah. It should that should that should do
it. So the question
yeah. You can
there's kind of two two sides to this
question.
We know that there's a lot of folks
out there that already have
huge investments in in how they run their
applications and how they provision them, how they
build them, and we try
really hard to work well with those.
So for example, if you already have something
that is provisioned outside of Namespace,
Namespace can refer you can refer to it
through Namespace. We won't automate it, but it
it will just work.
Now when you kinda bring when you come
into our our ecosystem,
we do make certain things easier. So for
example, what you the the question was referring
to volumes.
You could can define volumes as part of
your application, and we'll manage those for you.
We'll,
set up, like, the the volume sources and
kind of the amounts,
appropriately into into the into the application container
as well.
We'll manage sizes.
And then something that you'll be able to
do is apply
modifiers.
This is not implemented yet. Actually, it was
an idea that you, David, had some time
ago that is still in the in the
queue.
You there's two ways that you can do
configuration,
and one of them is you can parametize
within queue.
So you can go to the queue file
and say, hey. If this environment is for
development,
do these settings. If this environment is for
production or is named Fubar, do these other
settings. So that's kind of one way of
doing parametization,
and we'll have a second one that is
based on the target environment. So if you
say that I'm deploying to production, and in
production, I want this application to have
one terabyte
of of data or storage available in in
its volume,
you'll be able to provide configuration for that
as well. But that's not implemented yet.
Okay. Awesome.
We also had a comment from your colleague
just saying that persistent volumes are modeled and
namespace configuration. So maybe we'll, I don't know
what's in the demo, but perhaps we'll get
to something that shows how that works.
Our NSDev server
now worked.
We have a URL,
which says hello world,
which is our web application.
So
I'm gonna go off script for just a
moment because you said something
that is it monitors your changes.
So
I'm gonna make a change
and I'm gonna go to the web browser.
I'm not gonna do anything else.
Hey. Look at that.
We knew that you're going to do that
change, and we've
Yes. You intercepted the CCB traffic on the
the redirect. Yeah. In your local network.
That that's neat. That's one of those common
frustrations. Right? With with especially with compiled deployment
and that developer experience is that typically you
have to stop the world to the recall
file, spread it back out.
But
that was almost magic to the point where
I made that change and it probably took
about four or five seconds. And I could
see it on my little
macro stage manager thing there. It was doing
stuff in the background. I don't really know.
I'm assuming it just rebuild the image and
swap them out. Yeah. Okay. Yep. For go,
we do that.
If you would use the Node. Js integration,
we would copy the files that are changed.
And
and also we try always to
find the right
trade off
with giving controls whenever whenever it makes sense.
So for example, for when we build a
Go image,
for folks that are familiar with Co,
we actually use a very similar method to
Co. We use a local Go toolchain
to build your binary,
and it is Namespace that then builds an
image fairly quickly and kinda pushes that into
the repository.
And and we're we we do a lot
of these
things where we try to kind of really
optimize for for the developer
experience.
What we also didn't see is that you
never probably in your machine, you have Go,
but you never had to install Go.
We went and fetched Go
the first time that you did NSDEV,
and we placed it in our little cache.
And whenever you're you're you're kinda building that
that version is being used, if you change
your application and you update your the Go
version that your application is using, then we'll
fetch a different version of Go.
And and, again, like, you don't need to
manage that yourself.
And
I guess you're
leading me on that question there. Like, what
languages are supported then? Like, it sounds like
go is it's got pretty solid support. I'm
assuming namespace is right and go your go
developers. I can assume assume assumptions
all the way here. But
you mentioned Node. Js as well. So like
what Yeah. What are those first class languages
where what does it look like for languages
aren't supported?
So we the integrations that we have at
the moment are go, Node. Js, and we
call it Dockerfile.
There there's one more, which is Shellscript, but
I'll get to that in a moment.
So with Dockerfile, you can you you can
write the Dockerfile to
support whatever that you want. And and remember,
when you say integration Go, we're actually what
it's doing, it's
writing some of those definitions for you, but
you can always write them from scratch. You
can have a server definition that has all
of the services specced out, all of the
volumes specced out, like, manually.
So you can go and use, I don't
know, build a Rust server, and and it
will work. You just have to write a
Dockerfile.
But we do believe that we can do
better for users with these integrations, and there's
a couple more that are planned out for
Java and Python in particular.
So those are probably the ones that will
come after.
But those will also be extensible. So folks
will also be able to write their own
and and contribute builders,
contribute
kind of deployment configurations
that make sense for those.
One of the things that this getting started
doesn't cover, but our
testing facilities,
we capture
information out of the servers
after a test is run, And that's something
that the integration can tell us about. Like,
oh, this is a Go server. It can
you know, you can run pprof
against this endpoint and go and fetch some
some information out of that. So an integration
will be able to do things like that
as well.
Okay. So when you said that you download,
go to a local store and you use
that, that's really just for cool. Right? You
there's no need for you to download Rust
and do stuff or any other language on
time because that all happens in the container.
Yeah.
So we we
in this right now, we haven't used BuildKit
so far.
There there will be cases where we're using
BuildKit, we're building things in a container.
But for Go,
the development model
doesn't use
a container for building. If you run it
in CI,
then it will automatically
use
BuildKit, so it will kind of run-in a
container. So, yeah, it depends a little bit
on on
the thing that we're that we're building.
And this system that we have, we we
we
kinda we thought about it, but we actually
have since learned that a few other companies
are using
similar system. Cash App has
something that over open source called Hermit,
which which is an ability it gives you
the ability to
basically manage kind of pre already released software
in a way that it doesn't pollute your
your
your workstation,
and and you have a lot of control
over those versions. And that's similar thing that
you're seeing here. If you run maybe just
to show it once more,
you you can can leave this one, and
you can run n s
t for tools or n s tools and
kubectl,
and then just use get pod if if
you want.
I I don't know how to kubectl.
So
you see here, we're actually doing exactly the
same thing. We are getting kubectl,
for you, and, then we're we're running it.
And by default, when you run when you
use kubectl through NS, it will be configured
with the right namespace and and and the
right context and and all of that so
that you don't have to kind of think
about it. But there's always this idea that
you don't need to go and figure out
what to download.
We'll help you download, and we can manage
those downloads for you those dependencies for you.
Okay. We have a question on the chat
related to the it's gonna CI side of
things here, but George is asking, will there
be a base image of namespace that could
be used at a build server such as
GitLab?
Would that be an interesting question.
So
right now, the only distribution mechanism that we
have for Namespace itself is the binary. We
don't yet have
base images, but it would make sense that
we would have a base image. So I
think the answer is yes. We should have
one, but we don't have it yet.
Alright. Awesome. Hope that helps, Sean.
Okay.
Let's go back to our
our guide.
So
next, it wants us to okay. We've seen
that. We've changed it.
Is it gonna ask me to change it
next? No. Okay. Cool. New new thing.
We're gonna add menu to our setup.
So is this a new server?
Yes.
Okay.
So when we use the term server and
namespace world, this is a software component, a
package, something like that.
Yeah. A package can have multiple things. We
have servers,
we have tests,
we have binaries,
and and then these are the things that
live
so server is a type of thing that
lives in in a a package, but you
can have others.
Okay.
I've decided to call the file this time
random dot queue because I don't think it
cares and I wanted to confirm. But if
that is wrong, please feel free to just
tell me to shop and rename it.
We can try it.
Again, we have a name, we have an
image, we have no integration this time, but
we do have something called class stateful.
And then we have what I suspect is
familiar to everyone. We have the ability to
do environment, our services and mounts. This feels
very Kubernetes deployment a. So let's focus on
the class stateful.
Yeah. It's it's another one of those decorators.
In this case, it's not language specific, it's
behavior specific.
And it will
add a couple tests to our server. So
for example, if you want to use a
persistent volume,
you need to you're you need to have
a stateful class declared. You or else we
won't know exactly how or how you want
to manage that attached
storage.
It will also as you could imagine, when
you're deploying to Kubernetes, it will instantiate a
stateful set while other servers will instantiate deployments.
But even those are not fully set, like,
we we go from
what's the intent of the user, that's what
we're trying to capture here. Like, okay, you
want a stateful server.
And then depending on the current deployment strategy,
we'll we'll might be doing different things. So
in development, we'll do a stateful set. In
a test, we actually just deploy a single
pod with with this server.
Okay.
So the integrations and the languages that support,
there's a finite list. I understand that. The
classes, what's the discovery method for those? How
do people work out which classes are available
for their servers?
Yeah. Good
question.
We
we've been working we we we chat a
lot with the Q team.
We're big fans of Q.
One of the things that is
starting to surface in that space is a
powerful
LSP,
so we want to have integration to do
Versus Code.
And we've been designing our configuration
to be as standard queue as possible
so that we can benefit from from and
contribute to that ecosystem as well. So we
don't have that yet. We actually had a
version of an LSP, but it wasn't
with some changes that we've been doing, it
hasn't kind of kept up to date. But
that would be the discovery or or one
of the discovery mechanisms that you would have.
And then, obviously, we also have a syntax
reference in our documentation.
We're also happy to hear ideas of how
other folks
kinda prefer to to kind of get to
learn about these concepts. We we're trying to
do a mix of documentation
examples,
and then
in the near future also
integration into into editors.
Okay.
Awesome.
Hey. And those be for a second because
this is a question I don't think it's
gonna make sense to anyone else besides you
and your team. But
why server colon
rather than
like a queue definition?
Like, what's the
because I as soon as you said LSP
and standard queue, I was like, oh, but
how does it know
this
the types for the server definition? Yeah. We
haven't really used that. So is that I
I was just curious. That's all. Yeah. So
that's that's
you're you're hitting exactly
why our previous LSP work and currently doesn't
work. So we
the the first version of namespace
requires you to do those uni unification. So
you would have to say, hey. This is
a server that is unified with this
data type as well that kind of serves
as as a type definition in queue. So
you would have this server is a doll
hash server and
which is very common and folks that are
familiar with queue are are very familiar with.
But we found that to kinda be distracting,
honestly,
and as we're kind of getting people to
get to know about namespace.
So we've removed the need for that for
now. And what we've worked with the queue
team is that we'll have, this is not
implemented in queue yet, but we'll have the
ability to define at the module level which
base types are unified with a package.
So there will be a kind of a
base package, if you will, that we can
define, and then we say, well, if there's
a server,
that server is preunified
with hash server.
If there's a test, that's preunified with hash
test. And that's how the LSP then will
know because it will see kind of the
unification.
Alright. Next.
Cool. Thank you.
So
let's see if my random dot queue worked
then.
I'm assuming
I can run dev
and we call this menu.
Mhmm.
And it's good to just pull in the
menu image.
One
thing that we also don't
we don't really
it's not perhaps obvious to to folks that
are that are
seeing,
but your
machine, you're running I guess this is an
m one or m two
Mac.
And we
what we did was we kind of used
that information, like, know the environment that we're
deploying to to to pull and manage images
automatically.
So you never have to think about
well, obviously, there are cases in a in
a developer's life cycle that you might need
to know about the platform, but most of
the times, you don't need to manage platforms.
So if you'd go and do
prepare
EKS, for example, and your EKS nodes are
only x eighty six sixty four, we'll automatically
build for x eighty six sixty four and
deploy images of that
target platform,
which we obtained from the from the Kubernetes
clusters. We actually build
for that cluster. And we know that we're
building for Linux
because that's what's running inside of Docker,
ARM 64.
What do you do if it's not a
homogenous cluster?
We do a multiplatform builds. Nice.
So we unify over all of the platforms
that we see in the cluster,
and and we build for all of them.
And and, yeah, so that's something that Namespace
manages for you. It automatically generates indexes.
It parallelizes,
like, multi platform builds.
I discovered some sort of UI that I
didn't mean to click on, but I have
clicked on.
Yeah. This is a early stage of of
something that we
expect to be more
that folks will interact with with more over
time.
As you see, it's it's it like, the
the bits on the bottom are are not
really working,
so you may even have to
I I actually don't know if if if
you may have to go back. But
what what's one of the challenges that we
face as developers of this kind of multi
server world
is
there's so many logs. There's so many terminals.
There's, how do I there's so many ports.
Like, how do I manage all of this?
And our take is if you say that
there's a service,
and by default, we assume that the service
has a particular kinda meaning for you as
a developer, we automatically forward it. So
you're connecting inside of the cluster that is
running inside of Docker. So this is not
something that is available in your local network.
We actually are doing that port forward automatically
for you.
If you press the server, you'll get logs.
If you go into the terminal tab, you
get a terminal.
And
and that's something that we do for any
server in the stack.
And
main servers is is a hint that you
can actually have many of these. So you
could even run NSDEV
with with multiple servers and and and manage
them all from a single place.
Cool.
Alright. I see buttons. I can't help myself
but click. So Alright.
Yeah. I like that. So the UI was
nice.
I'm clicking on one more. I thought I
was checking on the manual UI, but it
took me to this, but it that'd let
me get to the manual API as well.
So nice to all of that stuff is
just right there waiting for me.
Alright, let's see what's next on our tutorial.
I appreciate that. We're getting close to like
our plan time and I feel like we've
got so much more that we need to
show people. So
maybe you can kind of guide us. What
what what should we be looking at next?
Should we keep working through this or is
there something that you think, hey, people need
to see this.
Let's
maybe I think we can just you can
just copy this one definition, and we'll connect
it to servers, which are the it's a
thing where we we feel like
brings value to to folks.
I think this is you you probably can
copy the whole thing.
And Okay. It's just a change to the
the server dot queue. Right? Yes.
Exactly. So here, we're kind of connecting the
two things. We're saying that,
hey. There's
this MinIO server.
The Go server needs your MinIO server for
folks that are familiar with Docker Compose. Like,
it's a similar idea.
But what's interesting here is that Namespace
understands these definitions across multiple packages.
So when you go and set up,
MinIO,
you don't need to kinda figure out, okay,
what's the port that is listening in and
and what's the what's the host?
You just say, like, in set up my
environment, my s three endpoint from a service
endpoint. So that means
from the API
that MinIO is exporting.
And you see this it's kind of condensed
into this string format, but it's package colon
and then the service name.
And you can refer to anything across packages.
And as you're going to deploy, you'll see
that that environment variable will have kind of
the right value for this deployment. And then
as you do different deployments, that value will
also be updated accordingly
based on deployment that you have.
There's just one nit because you named your
module something else. So here we say example.com/nsexample.
So that's our our package system
is trying to that's that's how we're telling
our package system, hey. Here's where to find
this. But, actually, the current module,
you named
you yeah. I think you named it Rawkode
Academy. So you we'll need to update one
of them for for this work. Oh, alright.
Okay. So this is the service from the
manual deployment. This doesn't change. This is a
package which is the same. However, this bit
here is Exactly.
Okay.
I've got you. And it was lowercase as
well. Yep.
And the same under requires.
Every time something goes wrong, I'm gonna show
it to my fault also.
I'll take the blame. I'm also happy. You
know,
what's what very much all like, I so
so very often as developers, as we're working
on an application, he's handling errors.
And, you know, something goes wrong, and and
so I'm always happy to just see, hey.
How is it failing? Because it's also an
opportunity for us to kind of understand, are
we already doing a good enough job telling
you how you can kinda fix things yourself,
or or do we need to do better?
Okay. So we have updated this with the
requires block.
And since
I I probably shut it. Did I shut
it down? Oh, no. It's still running. Okay.
So
this should already have
happened then. Right?
So it didn't because
and this is this is influx
actually.
We're
you you run NSDEV and then one server.
So we're looking for changes to that server.
We're not looking for changes for any change
inside of that repository.
Okay. So we see here now that it
actually said that there were two servers that
were deployed,
and, it will, by default,
focus on the one that you specified, which
was the Go server. But if you press
s, it will cycle through and show you
so one more once more.
Yeah. And then you'll see then support services.
You'll you'll see also the endpoints of these
other servers that you're deploying.
Nice.
So if I open a new tab,
run NS tool, keep control get pods.
We have our menu on our server. And
I'm assuming if I
describe
this pod, that s three environment variables just
gonna be kinda chilling,
which it is.
Okay, cool. I like how it's connecting everything
together and quite
this is quite a neat way of doing
it. It's like it's not overly I don't
need to apply too much cognitive awareness to
what's happening in the system. I'm literally just
saying I need this variable and it's coming
from some computed value within the stack, which
is neat.
And as it changes, like, you sometimes you'll
rename the service or
or now maybe that server is something else,
it will tell you. Right? Like, I think
that's one of the most powerful things, which
is keeping these semantic references in the code.
Like, what's your intent as a user? You
you actually want to connect these two things.
So whenever that's not true for some reason,
we can tell you, hey. This is not
working the way that you would expect it
to work versus just leaving some ports over
there, and then you go and change MINI
O to be on port 7,000 and and
it just doesn't work anymore.
Okay. So if I come in here, I'm
some Yep. Wildcard developer that's decided. Actually, this
is a a TLS API and I just
go and change this. I'm assuming this is
not gonna complain and tell me that it
can't fulfill It should complain.
There we go.
It it complains in a in a a
fairly hard to understand way.
Well, that's completely. Yeah.
Exactly.
Exactly. So it
so it's still not it's still not exactly
the problem that we should be seeing. Yeah.
This is a different problem.
It's just me not using DNS appropriately. Okay.
Now we've got API is not exported by
this module, which is a lot easier to
understand. Yeah. And you know why
it it took a second to do to
do that?
Because it,
internally,
there's two phases. So, there's actually three phases.
There's parsing as well, but there's planning
and execution.
And some of these values are only resolved
after we go and deploy something. So we
may have to deploy something until we know,
hey. This is actually the endpoint, and we
can go and update your,
Go server deployment to point at that value.
And so so that also means that we're
out of the box doing things in order.
So if you say when you say that
the server, kind of Go server, depends on
MinIO,
the first time that you're deploying,
we'll deploy MinIO first, wait for it to
become ready, and then we deploy the Go
server.
And this is
less important during development,
but especially in tests, which exactly the same
environment is used for.
It's really important that you kind of know
that your test is starting at the time
when the server is actually ready, and then
we're initializing the right order.
Okay. Cool. Got it.
Since because just being mindful of time, but,
obviously, David, you know best, I think what
could be interesting is just show
a quick example of a a few more
things coming together and
from our examples repository.
Yeah. That's good. And and then we can
just maybe highlight a couple things from there.
So if you could clone our examples repository,
then I can guide you through it.
What's the gahub
Namespace labs slash examples.
Alright. Where would you like to start?
I would go to one of the most
complete more complete ones, the multi tier.
And then
we have
whatever the latest number it is. Sorry. It's
actually hard for me to read. Yeah. Sorry.
The sidebar doesn't seem to scale with the
font size. So we've got simple web secrets
and web resources.
With numbers. Right? So whatever number is the
highest at the beginning. Yeah.
And in this multi tier
example, we have a Node. Js front end.
We have
Go server back end, and then we also
have,
a database,
server.
And,
this covers a lot of the functionality that
Namespace has. Maybe we could just run NS
dev for it, but you'll need to run
prepare local first.
Okay. So do I go into the multi
tier directory, do I do it from the
top? It's it's up to you. You can
also do it from here. Alright. Well, let's
do a multi tier, all three.
That puts me here, and let's prepare local.
So and and because we ran local before,
we, by default, target the same cluster,
but we use different Kubernetes
namespaces for different application workspaces.
So the previous
deployments that you saw will continue in our
local cluster. As we deploy things from a
completely different module or repository,
they'll they'll be in the same cluster but
in a completely different Kubernetes namespace.
And if you run NSDEV
front end
So it's it's now there's a bunch of
things happening. So the front end
depends on the API back end, which is
a Go server. The front end is written
in Node. Js,
and the back end then depends on Postgres.
And there's different options of how to deploy
Postgres.
We're going to use, the in cluster setup
that we have that is going to deploy
a Postgres server in the same cluster.
And, what you're seeing is we're we're actually
building the Node. Js application.
We're done with that.
We built the Go application before as well,
full parallelism. Some of that run-in BuildKit. Some
of that was local. We fetched the Postgres
image. And now what we're doing is,
we're kind of orchestrating these changes. So first,
we're going to deploy the Postgres server.
It took a little bit of time.
We actually have a bug in the timings
there, so but the o OSS Postgres server
was the first thing to deploy.
Then,
the Go server
uses a database that is created out of
that cluster, so that is running what we
call a provider.
So that's code that will run inside of
the cluster to go and set up the
database for you.
And and then we run the ghost the
we we deploy the ghost server, and then
we deploy the front end. And if we
look then at the server definitions, it's all
kind of references very much like before.
So we
yeah. As
you should
Oh, no. I got it. I think you
have two gets.
No. It it's it's correct. I think it's
just because you have two gets.
It
happens to me all the time.
Yeah.
There we go. There we go. Okay. Cool.
So, yeah, we got a separate namespace. We
have all of our services on this namespace.
We have our
web UI, which lets us get to the
front end of the application.
Mhmm.
Very neat. Very Yeah. And and if you
type in into this application, it's sending your
request to the go back end, which then
is storing that data in Postgres.
And I
think what what
the what we're aiming for is imagine you're
in development team. You just joined that team,
and and there's a stack that everyone is
is kind of using to to kinda build
their application.
And how often is just a bunch of
documents that you have to run through,
install this, and and run this command, and
get authorization for that. And here, we kinda
we we really try to encapsulate that whole
experience into well, you have NS. NS will
kinda manage the whole environment for you, and
we'll get you to an to the same
sort of development environment that anyone else in
your team has because all of those dependencies
are pinned. We know that they're the right
versions,
and and it gets you to that final
setup.
Okay. So you mentioned earlier
when we spoke briefly about Node. Js that
it works a little bit differently from Go
and that the system is actually synchronized. Now
I've seen this with a few tools in
the past and the challenge always seems to
be
that speed of reflecting those changes
over the fail thing can be a little
bit slow. So do you mind if we
if we test that? Sure.
So
if I change the title of the page
to Stargate is better than Star Trek,
I like to be talking first. It reject
the change just because it's wrong.
Oh, no. I don't have Actually I've got
local host. Where's my title? My
browser doesn't show one. Okay. Let's make another
change. Mhmm.
So this I'm assuming
I'm gonna have to
change some CSS or something background
to be white.
Oh, wow. That was fast.
Yeah.
But it's not good enough yet.
It's
it the
the reason for it is we're we're we're
we weren't inspired by some of these other
tools. And what we see folks do is
they look at your file system,
looked at the files change, kind of ship
that over to the container.
Now
that means that there will be kind of
subtle
cases where the changes inside of the container
don't fully track what's in your workstation.
So we have a few ideas of how
we can improve that.
Notably,
bringing to Kubernetes something that feels a lot
more like volume volume
mounts from from Docker, where it's literally like
your file system that is exposed.
And we're kind of keen to to do
some of those. We just haven't gotten to
it yet. But but we want to get
to a point
that
developing
in an environment that is actually Kubernetes
feels as good, if not better,
than local development. And we know that the
TypeScript and JavaScript ecosystems are ahead. Like, it's
much better for you to go and do
NPM dev or YARN dev today than deploying
to Kubernetes,
but you you lose so much on the
way. Like, there's so many compromises that you're
doing
around how production like your environment is, and
we want to get to a point where
you feel that you're
developing in a production like environment without making
those compromises. So we're we're we're we'll continue
to invest in in getting there.
Okay. Let me throw a question out to
you then. Like, we've really focused today on
what that developer experience looks like with Namespace.
Let's assume,
know, people wanna start kicking the tires unless
they wanna loop it into their own systems.
Is there any is there any penalty and
it's drawbacks for people that only want to
use it in-depth or is that like or
is that like free go for it? This
will this will help you and then it's
up and to production or do you feel
as a loaded question, but should people go
all out and use Namespace from from start
to finish?
Yeah. It's a great question, and and it's
it's a common question. So thank you for
asking because
it can sometimes feel daunting when you have
this all in one systems. Like, okay. Now
I have to go through this decision of
of changing everything that I'm doing.
And
we we're developers ourselves, and we know how
costly these are. So our philosophy is we
want to use the bundling
on on for the benefit of the developer,
for the for for the benefit of the
development teaming as well. So you can go
and use develop Namespace only for development. That's
totally okay. You can have Terraform to deploy
to production.
You can use our image building system, but
you can also just keep your Docker files
or anything else that you use to build
production images. You can do that.
You can then go from development and add
whole system testing, and that's kind of a
very incremental
cost. There's actually almost zero cost
for you as kind of a user of
Namespace. And and and now you have a
set of capabilities that probably you didn't have
before
compared with to the way that you were
doing development before. And then you can also
do production,
and we care deeply about production as well,
but it's it's opt in. It's not something
that you have to do from day one.
Okay. Awesome. Thank you.
I know how you are for time. If
you have a hard stop or if we
could maybe go a little bit over, but
what's kind of top of my mind right
now is that we've taken a look at
this more complete example
where
if I stop playing with the JavaScript code
for a moment and look at the server
Is that this just says, hey, I'm an
integration web.
I speak to some sort of back end.
When we go to the back end, we
see that that has its own server dot
queue.
This has some resources.
So it's looking database and obviously this is
like, you need
postgres.
Can we take a look because I'm assuming
people are gonna get to a point where
they wanted to do this. Already wanna replace
all of my development pipelines with namespace.
And my first thing is that, okay, well
I use MongoDB for the CMS.
I use
Redis over here. There's gonna be a point
where I have to write my own definition
of what this server looks like. So I
pulled up
your foundation and I thought maybe we could
take a look at the postgres one and
anything else that you think is interesting. So
people get a feel and a taste for
at some point, I'm gonna have to do
some heavy lifting and as that actually heavy
lifting or is this 20 lines of queue?
Like, I don't know yet. And
yeah, I'm happy to to still cover that.
I I
think it's interesting to kind of cover this
this resource part of
of Namespace as well. If you don't mind,
just one minute before we jump into the
into library, which where those definitions are, I
would just say, I think it's just useful
to kind of introduce people to some of
the concepts here
so that we can so that we can
map them back to to what we're going
to see.
So previously, we had, like, requires. So this
server requires this other server. Now this is
under the resource block,
and this this server says, well, I declare
a resource, which is a to dos database.
It's of a class database,
which lives in their database Postgres.
So that's kind of the type
is provided
by this library OSS Postgres, so you can
imagine that that means Postgres.
And there's something called intent, so that's the
the definition
that is used as an input for this
resource.
And in this case, it's, well, what's the
database name,
and do you have a set of series
of schemas that you want to be applied
automatically?
And then we there's a kind of an
advanced feature here that we can pass resources
to resources. So it's actually a composable
system. So we we pass the Postgres cluster
in,
and which we can have as many clusters
as you want. So this system is kinda
recursive
or supports recursive definitions.
And so class
is a type.
Provider is
is a thing
that
provides
an instance of that type, and that's what
we're going to see back in the code
base.
Okay. So I wanna see if I can
make that a little bit more concrete for
people to understand. Sure. So the class says,
this is what the definition of a post
grad database looks like some sort of contract.
Don't think it's important what that looks like,
but the provider
and
please correct me if I'm wrong,
could be OSS postgres may be running the
container image from the official Docker Hub library.
But in theory, this could be RDS postgres
and that's what actually spin up and manage
postgres on AWS.
So the provider changes
that. Is that correct?
That's exactly correct. Okay. Sweet.
The intent, I didn't fully understand other than
is inputs and I understand that this is
the database name and this is the some
local schema that it wants to run. So
I'm just going to take your word for
that. That's what happened.
So
assume that is this defined by the class?
Is this what determines what else is in
this property, these fields here?
That's right. It's
the class defines
two types. One is what are my inputs
and what's my output.
And so in the case of inputs for
a database is name and a set of
schemas schema files, and outputs are
the Postgres database endpoint
credentials that may be needed to connect to
that endpoint
and the database name as well.
And those are then injectable into your server.
So if you go up in the same
server definition,
oh, or perhaps down. Sorry.
Oh, sorry. We actually so there's two ways
that we do injection. And in this example,
I had forgotten that we we dynamically consume
that.
We automatically
generate a config map that gets in that
gets mapped into your server with runtime configuration,
including these resources,
including
what are your own services that you're exporting,
what was your own image, which development environment
are you coming from. And this example is
reading those from that file, not but you
could map them. You could inject, for example,
the Postgres endpoint
into an environment variable
the same way that we did it before.
But rather than being from service endpoint, we
would say from resource field so we could
actually go and fetch that value.
Nice.
Okay. Cool.
Is there anything else in this file that
we need to go over before we look
at the library?
No. There there's just another concept here, which
is tests,
and and maybe
I think folks can also explore that by
themselves. If you run NS test,
what we're going to do is we are
going to instantiate the same stack that you
saw so we cannot deploy the same set
of servers, but in a separate namespace.
We call it an ephemeral
namespace, which is used for this for for
that test.
And then we deploy a client binary,
which is your test code that you write
yourself in whatever language that you want that
is running as a client inside of the
cluster. So it can do it can it
has private networking. So it can reach the
the server endpoints directly.
And our philosophy for testing,
not for everything, but but is but for,
comprehensive testing is having wholes whole system tests.
So kind of writing a client as if
it was a real client that is exercising
kind of the real API passage as you
would inside of the cluster, and that's what
this testing subsystem
allows you to do.
Alright.
I'm gonna give a huge shout out to
your teammates who have tackled a bunch of
questions.
Well, we've been They're awesome. Yeah. But there
is one right at the bottom there that
hasn't been answered yet. And I actually feel
it's quite important, so I'm I'm gonna throw
that out. But why I'm always asking about
secrets? How do we handle secrets in the
Namespace environment?
Yeah. So we we
have a
secret implementation. So secrets are a first class.
We
understand secrets
in Namespace.
And the implementation that we have
manages secrets on your behalf,
but we focus on,
I think it's fair to say, like, simpler
team,
based scenarios.
We don't focus, like, full productionized
secret scenarios yet. Like, the secret implementation
for production will be pluggable, like other parts
are in are in our system. It's not
the case yet.
What we do today is you
you can define a secret here, and then
we'll tell you, well, do you need to
specify a value for it? We'll,
we'll give you a command, which is n
s secret set that writes a local file
that you should commit into your repository, but
it's encrypted.
And,
it uses a series of a series of
keys for those that are familiar with age,
which is kinda a
tool that is kinda commonly used for for
kind of encrypting data. We we we manage
age keys for you. So each developer has
an age key.
Then everyone that should have access to that
secret file is added to that secret file.
Every time that you add new secrets, we
re encrypt the file so that everyone in
the team has access to it. So whenever
you go and deploy something,
you have direct access to those secrets. They're
never committed clear text into the repository.
Then when it goes to stored?
Only in your local machine. Never
never revealed to us, never revealed to the
repository.
Okay. So what if I change machine,
do I lose access?
By default, yes. You can generate a new
key. So you go NS keys generate,
and and that behind the scenes uses age
to generate a new key, and then you
can ask a team member
to add you to the to the secrets
file,
which when we add a reader,
it re encrypts so you you will have
access to it. And
or or you can use your previous machine
to do that yourself.
Okay. So I should probably just back up
that private key, like, if I plan on
working for multiple machines?
Honestly,
like, the model that we followed is more
like a key per system.
So it's kind of
easier to reason about revocation.
But having said that, this is not designed
for production.
This is really just to assist development. What
often ends up in these files are secrets
that are used for development,
And we'll have a we'll have something that
integrates with Doppler and something that integrates with
Vault later on
as part of Namespace when you go to
production. You've already mentioned my favorite secret provider.
I use Doppler every day for everything. It
is fantastic.
And the free tier is ridiculous. Like, I
just work in projects on my own, I
never have to pay them any money and
they do all the time.
Yeah. There's there's I must say, I mean,
there's incredible software out there and we we
try to lean on it whenever it makes
sense. And, yeah, someone else already tackled secrets
for us. And for us so so for
us, it's really just about going and doing
a good job of integrating with them so
that it doesn't feel like, you as a
developer have to go out of your way.
And,
you know,
I I I can imagine how many people
have gone through this, and I I'm just
tired of
to use tool a, go to login,
go to settings, generate key, copy key. Like,
we we're trying to kinda really streamline that
whole experience, and and we even have ideas
of how to incorporate OAuth into
OAuth web flows into some of these so
that when you go and provision
something that can be can use OAuth authentication,
we actually kick you into a OAuth
authentication flow so that you don't have to
manage any more keys.
But these are these are things that will
come in the future. They're not there today
yet. Very cool.
Alright. I've already kept you way over time.
Is there anything else
you wanna show before we wrap up to
this session?
I think we could kick off or or
we could just finish this since we're here.
We could just do NS test because it's
one of those things that
I think folks
I hear people, like, we cannot run, like,
comprehensive tests whether
whether we're testing our front end or we're
testing our our back ends, and it's a
lot of folks
end up leaning on mocks and and and
really kind of underrepresented systems.
And we're trying really hard to make that
simple
but also cost efficient. Like, you don't want
to wait for hours for it to for
these run tests to run.
So when you define a test with
with NS, as I said, like, we're just
going to deploy that stack for you, and,
and then your testing code becomes a client
inside of the cluster. And what we saw
here, like, you're running all the tests that
are in the repository.
By default, the strategy is one at a
time. So we build in parallel, and that's
why you see a lot of things going
on right now. We're basically building all of
the tests and all of the examples.
But then we're
deploying one test at a time,
and that's what we saw before. And then
we said kind of collecting collecting post execution
server logs. We'll see that at the end
that we run that test, and then we
not only collect the logs of your test
driver, but we also collect the logs of
all the servers involved
in that test,
during the duration of the test. And in
the future, we'll also collect
metrics. We'll collect network traffic between those tests
so that you can understand,
what actually happened. You can debug,
and you can, better review some of the
changes that you're doing and how they affect
some of the tests. So we use tests
a lot because that's a way for us
to have confidence that, that we're shipping things
at work.
But you'll go through our code base, and
you'll see very few
unit tests, actually, but, quite a bit of
these kind of end to end tests
because we we really want to go for
that full represent representation.
And so here, it's going it's because it's
running everything, you'll see it just takes a
little bit of time. We have
options that allow you to increase parallelism,
and we have a product coming next year
that,
we call them instant clusters
where, whether it's in our infrastructure or on
on your infrastructure, you'll be able to spin
up, like, a cluster from scratch in a
few seconds,
and and the target is is exactly
kinda running this test. We want you to
be able to run twenty,
fifty, one hundred tests in parallel
and
but in fully isolated environments.
Yeah. This is pretty neat. I had no
idea I was running every test in the
entire repository,
but I'm also kinda glad to edit because
it's been kind of fun watching us kinda
scroll by and then tick, tick, tick, tick,
and then we got past past past past.
So, yeah, that was cool. I like that.
It's
it's also satisfying in some way that
it does all that work and then and
then obviously when when things work, it's good.
But but, we developer experience is so important.
And, right now, we'll tell you that, well,
you're testing in past and and that and
and here's why.
But we have so many ideas of how
we can improve that whole troubleshooting,
journey that you go as you're developing software.
We want to bring into Namespace
so that, again, you don't have to go
and figure out how to do diff use
different tools for that. You just run NSS.
It gives you a in a kind of
a URL that you can click. It will
show you what happened, whether it's logs, whether
it's traffic,
who called who,
and and just kind of so that you
have, like, a tool that helps you
as you're building a robust software. We care
deeply about robust software.
Awesome.
Well,
that was really cool. I I think you're
you're sneaking in just before the December 1
is like potentially
my favorite project of 2022.
Like this is super cool. And it's one
of those spaces that I am very passionate
about. Think especially with Kubernetes adoption, microservices,
cloud native health to some degree, is that
a lot of the things we used to
take for granted that were simple and they
become inherently complex.
And Namespace
with the way that it provides these obstructions
and reusable components and provides a developer experience.
I'm very excited about it. I've gotta be
honest. I'm I'm very very happy that you
joined me today and I can't wait to
see what comes next. I think there's so
much more. Sorry. I'm just gonna keep blabbing
at you, I think there's so much more
we we can show and I think we're
gonna have to schedule some sort of other
episodes in the coming weeks or something like
that just to to get through all.
I would love to come back, and I
I really appreciate
the opportunity, David. And on I've been a
follower for for for a long time, and
so it's it's actually
a pleasure and an an honor to to
be here because I I I
really appreciate how you approach kind of problem
solving and and and your passion for for
the ecosystem that we share.
I welcome folks to try it out and,
you know, and come and talk with us.
Like, we we're developers just like you, and,
we want to build great software. And, we'll
only be able to build great software if
we, learn from all of you on what's
what's kind of important and what are the
things that we should be looking at. And
if you're passionate about open source and want
to contribute, we're happy to have you. So
come on board.
Awesome. Well, I'll make sure that the links
to the Twitter and Discord are in the
show notes shortly after this. So if you've
watched this session and you like what you
see, join the Discord, ask questions, get help
and even contribute back. There's lots to be
done. But the start that we have here
is very exciting. So Hugo and to your
team in the comments, thank you so much
for all your hard work. I'm going to
experiment more and hopefully we'll speak soon.
Any last words? The big props to my
team. Yeah. They're they're awesome. Like, I wouldn't
be here without them. So thank you.
Alright. Awesome. Have a wonderful day. I'll we'll
see you all soon until next time. Bye.